你要问我你能不能带着这个男的一起做，
我说句良心话，
你不带着他做的话，
他可能未必知道你能挣那么多钱，
你一旦带着他做，
他知道你能挣那么多钱的话，
他会觉得你都是我的，
你挣的钱当然也是我的。
前几天我老公跟我说，
他套信用卡炒股亏了9个左右嘛，
他为什么愿意跟我说，
是因为我在这之前我跟他分享了我今年创业取得的成果和对未来的展望，
让他非常有信心的跟我一起做，
我跟他结婚10年哦，
其实他一直有在断断续续一直在有套信用卡炒股啊，
Pup什么的，
只是我知道的时间节点，
一个是这几天他告诉我的，
一个是去年还是前年，
还有一个就是我怀二胎6个月的时候，
他告诉我，
他告诉我的时间节点都是她自己计算好的哈，
都是让你没法干，
翻出什么遗忘的时候他告诉你，
对，
因为她第一次告诉我的时候，
是我怀二胎6个月的时候，
她掐这个时间告诉我的，
但是后面孩子也生下来了，
慢慢的就这样走到了现在嘛，
我原本是想让她打算我们一起做的，
但是回想这些点滴，
我觉得让他跟我一起做有点害怕，
他真的是不确定性太多，
一直在算计我，
很yes，
这样子如果你自己过，
或许你还能为孩子。
喷出一片天，
你跟孩子还能活得下去，
如果你觉得这个心性不太稳定的男人，
他每一次亏了都是踩着你翻不了浪的时间节点来告诉你，
他亏了钱，
每一次都是踩中了这个节点，
那你问我，
他以后跟你做，
他心情会改变吗？
那这事儿你自己心里没数吗？
还有一点，
他跟我分享了他这些年的历程吗？
他说他为什么去做心，
是因为不甘心，
想试试，
但是这几年确实是没有赚到钱，
而且还亏掉了，
所以他现在自己彻底觉悟干了，
信用卡注销掉，
工资交给我什么的，
他这样表较决心，
我昨天让他签了一份协议嘛，
协议他是签掉了，
但是我对他确实有点害怕，
不是很放心他，
那你就自己做你的，
他那一头他有工作吗？
他自己一直有工作，
那他有工作，
他就踏踏实实干他的工作，
我有拉他的征信，
呃，
欠款确实如他所说，
如果还有其他途径的欠款，
会不会不在这个上面显示，
有可能，
因为并不是所有的网贷都能上征信，
有很多网贷他是不上征信的，
他是属于民间的，
这种私人的借贷，
他是没有资格上征信的，
前前后后大概出去70来个吧，
就是这样七十几个，
就是他总共亏了70多万了，
是不是他是这样跟我说的，
我也没办法查的。
很清楚，
这些查不了，
那我觉得第一你已经签了协议，
现有的夫妻的财产是归你了，
现有的这些经济你是保住了，
是不是对他是没有钱的，
我自己手上有钱，
也都是我自己辛苦赚的，
你要问我你能不能带着这个男的一起做，
我说句良心话，
你不带着他做的话，
他可能未必知道你能挣那么多钱，
你一旦带着他做，
他知道你能挣那么多钱的话，
他会觉得你都是我的，
你挣的钱当然也是我的。
男人的思维都这样，
我直播间有男人，
对不对？
男人一旦跟一个女人掉了，
他就有这种想法，
人都是我的，
你挣的钱当然是我的，
我为什么不能来支配？
我为什么不能说我想投资的项目，
你把钱拿给我，
为什么不可以对他，
这次为什么能跟我坦白，
能跟我讲这些，
就是因为他看到我的成绩很好，
想跟我一起，
他才愿意做这些的。
以前他的钱都是他的，
从来工资都没有给过我的。
所以我建议你自己的钱自己好好保护，
自己的事业自己好好维系。
如果说他只是亏了钱，
他没有乱搞男女关系，
咱们夫妻还可以继续做，
但是呢，
协议签了，
你的债务归你，
你的财产也归你，
你说你缺衣少穿吃什么的，
我可以养着你，
但你想来染指我的事业，
想要来染指我挣钱的这个门道，
那我对不起，
我要找。
合伙人的话，
我得找旗鼓相当的啊，
且没有在商言商，
你要找合伙人，
要一起做的话，
找那种旗鼓相当的，
他也是心性很稳，
他也是吃苦耐劳，
他也是稳扎稳打，
找合伙人要找这样的，
而不是找这种好高骛远的，
一口想吃个胖子的，
想要冒险的啊。
是的，
在他告诉我之前，
我真的是以为他改了，
你知道吗？
我就想着孩子都我两个，
两个人好好一起干，
我一个人也确实忙不过来，
但是他跟我坦白这些，
呃，
回忆起夜以前的种种，
我越想内心越害怕，
内心感觉很危险，
反而这样子我感觉还踏实一点，
供你参考啊。
有一个我就想让你觉得我老公是一个非常自私无情的人，
我怀孕六个月的时候，
他第一次告诉我，
他在外面欠了30多个好，
那时候我是没有什么钱的，
第一时间知道我肯定是生气的，
但生气归生气，
我还是想着把账还了好好过嘛，
还了之后我多少是有点怨气的，
因为我生活中有点怨气，
他都没有办法包容我，
挺着6个月肚子面对这些纷争，
最后掉的孩子生下来了，
慢慢的走到今天前，
现在我算是自己爬出来了，
还以为他变好，
但是他这样又一次跟我坦白，
我真的是好无语，
我好像还是自己一个人做比较好，
反正我跟你讲的都是我自己的这种人生经验吧，
我很害怕，
你知道吧，
对那种赌性很大的人，
我特别。
害怕，
因为他那个赌性一旦起来了之后，
有的时候会吞噬他的善良，
吞噬他的责任，
噬他的灵魂，
你看看现在那种什么，
他欺骗宝的，
结了个婚，
游轮上就把老婆往海里推的，
他们这些人的背后，
你去研究案例，
你会发现大部分都是赌性比较大的人，
他都是什么做什么大买卖，
亏了多少钱了，
或者干什么事儿亏了很多钱了，
欠一屁股烂债了，
有窟窿了，
才会去引发那些恶性的案件，
包括你们知道的王暖暖是吧，
王暖暖的那个事情，
他的背后那个男的也是有债务，
也是有赌的成分在里头，
其实这个不光是牌桌上，
这个才叫赌，
像你的老公他透支信用卡去做投资，
透支信用卡去炒股，
他本质上也是赌，
赌性很大的人，
到最后的话，
我们是很难拿我们的命去做一个测试，
测试他会不会回心转意，
测试他会不会变得成熟稳重，
测试他会不会回归家庭，
很难做这个事情呢，
就是不确定性态多啊，
对他爸爸好像年轻的时候也后面也不，
他昨天嗯，
跟我说的心理历程看着还挺真切，
他难不供你参考啊，
你反正守住自己的钱，
你还能堡护孩子，
你跟孩子还有一个活路，
你要是守不住自己的钱，
守不住自己挣钱的门道，
惨的是你，
惨的是孩子。
是的，
小宇君为什么会说我生二胎，
就是因为我第一次知道的时间节点就是。
胎的时候6个月，
面对这些纷争，
后面生下来我就当他死呀，
我一个人拖两个，
我也拖不动，
慢慢的拖好了，
过到现在对不对？
就是这样才有二年，
时间点都是他算计好告诉我的，
但我还有更多的方法去保护我自己，
面对他这种其实有一个釜底抽薪的方法，
但是他不一定同意离婚不离家，
有一个慢不会同意，
不同意那也是没办法哈，
行行，
我知道了，
你的事业，
你的钱，
你找合伙人，
你找到比较容易信任的合伙人的话，
就有些钱，
有些事业未必要放在自己的名下干，
就这样啊。
嗯，
刚刚有个人在评论区反驳吗？
他说难道做生意就是赌博吗？
不是的，
你要听这个故事的全貌，
这个故事的全貌是男的抓信用卡透支借款去炒股，
那我问你，
从这个角度来说的话，
不就等于赌博吗？
没错吧，
你说你有100万，
你花十万二十万去炒股，
这叫正常的投资行为，
你说你没钱，
你借10万20万，
借30万、
50万去炒股，
这玩意儿不跟我一样吗？
我是这么理解的啊，
我觉得没有钱的人借钱去炒股就跟我是一样的。
记得点赞关注哦。